ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show
no video this week
we have had a succession
of disasters that have prevented us
from recording in our usual studio
we are sitting in my backyard
in palm springs california
during the high season which is
apparently when everybody
comes out here to be in the desert
during the winter
i like it in the summer when nobody's
here and it's 125 degrees
prevents people from getting too
emotional
really keeps uh keep the riots at bay
when it's 125 degrees
but now it's cool and people are coming
back out here
all the desert rats are back out
all the creatures
i had the maid come in and i
the guy i usually use brought in a new
maid
her and her husband who did what they
call a deep covered
clean which nobody asked them to do
this is not an urgent care it's my home
the chemical smell of the deep covered
clean
is such that i cannot sit in my home
i don't know if i can sleep here but it
is
safe apparently from covert
ben walked in and his eyes started
watering
his throat got scratchy yep i mean
it is it is it is bleach is it ammonia
what is
it it's clorox man it's that clorox
bleach
the entire [ __ ] house
is completely so of course
we got to go get candles
and we went and got candles at cvs
and the meth had his cvs is unhappy
i asked her where the candles are she
goes well we have glade plug-ins i'm
like well those aren't candles
you know the difference
don't get an attitude with me i'm sorry
the state took your child
it's not my fault candle like you light
with a lighter
you know about lighters don't you you
know what lighters are
you know how to light things on fire
candles
so finally she's like yelling at us
she's like i told you it's in 23 she's
white by the way so if i do an accent
that sounds black
she was white it's we're talking meth
palm springs meth
white and she looked irish which
wouldn't shock anyone
and she was just like the candles are on
aisle
23 i told you where they were
and i'm like listen
we're here to get some holiday candles
because my maid did a covent clean
and we can't breathe you know about not
breathing right
that's what the emt says when they pick
your lifeless body off your kitchen
floor
you scumbag she's a rat
pig
and that's we got out here in the high
season we got degeneres
then we had to go to dairy queen because
we worked ourselves up an appetite
and then there's a problem in the dairy
queen there's a guy
in a in a pickup truck that stalled out
screaming onion
rings at the top of his lungs not even
in the general direction of of the
[ __ ]
whatever they what do you even call that
in a fast food thing the drive-through
uh
speaker box yeah whatever yeah yeah he
was the one one car behind
he's not even uh and he's just yelling
out of his window
at the sky onion rings onion rings
get me onion rings
the car in front of him the guy's
telling the woman every different kind
of slushy they have
every kind of slushie that's available
at
at 11 p.m at dairy queen
in cathedral city california right next
to the subway drive-thru
as bill hicks would say if you need a
point of reference
right next to the subway drive-thru
because subway made the very smart
decision
of letting people get handed a foot long
hero
through a window if they didn't want to
get out of their car
i mean i can't breathe it's so [ __ ]
so don't complain about the sound
quality don't complain about there's no
video just
[ __ ] let it be
enjoy life
it's a real i feel like the last four
years we've all been on drugs
trump is a drug for the people that love
him
and for the people that hate him he's
been a drug
everybody's been hopped up on trump
the media hollywood
his supporters everybody
and now the party's over
and people are still acting
like the party's still going on like you
know when you used to get [ __ ] up with
people in high school
and they pretended they were more drunk
than they were
and you knew that they weren't that
[ __ ] up or when you would trip
out with somebody and they clearly had
come down and they're like i'm still up
there man and it's like no you're not
get us in the car and drive us somewhere
you're fine
that's what trump supporters hardcore
trump supporters
are acting like right now they're
pretending they're still drunk
at a party in high school they're like
dude i'm
[ __ ] up dude we're gonna win
we're gonna win bro [ __ ] georgia
dude i'm so [ __ ] wrecked right now
bro
are you ready it's like you're not
wrecked we know you're not wrecked
you're not drunk anymore
you're not even drunk you barely had
anything to drink
we saw you you're barely
barely drunk you can legally drive you
just pretended to fall down you can
legally drive
and that's where we are right now in
this great land
we have people and then there's people
even on the other side like they're like
he'll never go away
he'll never leave it's like this shit's
all gonna end dude
covent is gonna end trump is going to
end
and you have to accept the reality where
those things are not running your life
anymore
and i know that's depressing to many of
you because
even though you might have loved or
hated trump he was this
sense of stability you're gonna wake up
the president was gonna tweet something
[ __ ] up and then there was this plague
outside that prevented you from doing
anything those things are gonna come to
an end
we're at dinner the other night and
people are like
trump's gonna have this big media empire
and i'm like
i'm going on record now and i could be
wrong
but i'm going record on record right now
i don't think he will
i don't think trump's going to have a
massive media empire
it takes a ton of capital can you give
me a bottle of water from that
thank you i'm sorry i don't want to make
you breathe in the [ __ ]
ben's very sensitive i spent 10 years
doing cocaine so i can't really
smell a ton but ben's very like i can't
i
can't understand why they would do this
with the chemicals
and i know i don't understand it either
they were doing a deep covert clean
because apparently they thought this was
a [ __ ] hospital
this house is cleaner than a hospital
right now
this is cleaner than the er ben the
bottle of water is right there on the
bar
you don't need to get just get the
bottle of water on the bar please
and bring it out here i called the guy
who sent the maids i'm like dude what
the [ __ ]
i like this guy too
but he sent this husband a wife couple
and they're a real [ __ ] problem
the regular maid it's her birthday so
she went away for the weekend
what was i saying before that
yeah this he's not going to start a
media empire well i mean he might try
you need a lot of capital to start a
media empire people don't seem to
realize that you need tons and tons of
capital
right and i just don't think
he's going to do it i could be wrong
i might be wrong i just don't know he's
going to start a media empire
people seemed very upset last night when
i kind of were telling him like this is
ending
the movie is ending they were like no
no he's crazy he's not going away one of
the guys at the table goes
he's not going away he's gonna have a
media empire it's gonna be bigger than
ever i'm like are you children this is
like people in high school
before they go to college going dude
we're still gonna be best buds forever
you're not you're probably not
maybe statistically you're not
some guy you know some guy says his
girlfriend is like even though we're
going to different schools
we're still going to [ __ ] love each
it's you're not
it's over have a few summer [ __ ]
and those are the tweets he's tweeting
out right now that's a few summer [ __ ]
because it's ending things
end and i think that this has been such
a
visceral experience for so many people
it has been really really impactful and
they
their entire sense of reality is wrapped
around
this guy and people's reaction to this
guy
that the idea of there not being a
donald trump
or it not being like this huge fight
every minute of every day the drama the
excitement
people are this is like drug addicts
coming down
we're coming down we're being weaned off
a drug that we've all been on for four
years
and somebody goes to dinner last night
to go he's gonna run again
in four years are you people nuts
how bad do you need this guy the oxygen
trump takes all the oxygen out of the
room
he's gonna run again he's gonna have a
media empire
and then he's going to run again he's
not going anywhere
yeah he's going to go somewhere he's
going to die eventually
when you're going to handle that then
somebody at the table goes i think
ivanka will run
there's just no thought that this is
coming to an end
right
same thing with coven it's coming to an
end folks
not tomorrow not soon but eventually
it's going to come
to an end we're going to get a vaccine
or there's going to be herd immunity
and we're going to move on and i know
that that's tariff people are like
terrified of moving on
from these two situations you talk to
people they don't like they don't even
like to hear that when i go covered
it's gonna end they're going oh i don't
know about that
i'm like do you not want to end are you
invested in this being the reality
forever
oh i don't think it'll end well i don't
think so
people go people are gonna wear masks
forever nothing will ever go back to
normal
no one will ever leave their house again
this is just the way it [ __ ] is
i'm like well in many states they're
leaving their house now
no this won't end trump's gonna have a
media empire
we'll live in this reality forever and
i'm like it's it's i've been to rehab
i've sobered up off drugs
if this is very similar to addict
behavior in in
early sobriety early sobriety
is all about the idea that
you're learning to let go of the things
and the people that you had built this
life around as a drug addict needing
this drug the rituals
the the people the places the things all
of that
have to change early sobriety later on
you get deeper into why you're a [ __ ]
addict and you go [ __ ] me
i should go to a therapist i gotta deal
with [ __ ] right
but early sobriety is all about like
okay i can't hang out with bill
anymore because he's a problem
so we're an early sobriety right now a
lot of people are sobering up
q anon is it's a real rough time now
i just hired a personal trainer i'm
trying to get him in the queue and on
right now
just to get him down a rabbit hole so it
doesn't [ __ ] bother me
but i just hired a trainer i've been
told to hire a trainer forever
and i just hired a [ __ ] trainer and i
started trying to get him in the queue
on the low started texting him i'm like
hey man have you heard about this
he's like yeah i've been hearing
something about that i'm like why don't
you start reading about that
he's like so what'd you eat today i'm
like why don't we talk a little bit
about q and on
for a minute let's just let's just say
there's bigger problems than what i had
for breakfast
let's just try to let's just try to
solve a few riddles that were posted
on the internet sir just before we get
to the training session
let's talk a little bit about q
but the queuing on people i mean it's
going they're gonna sober up
like a cult it's a few years ago like
yeah man i was yeah
people you know they're gonna do netflix
documentaries like you know leah remini
is
talking about scientology there's and by
the way is that even interesting there's
like 25 documentaries
about people that used to be in
scientology who gives a [ __ ]
yeah you thought you were an alien and
made 10 million dollars why do we have
to hear about it forever
are you people heroes i don't even
understand i mean didn't you torture
children too
what are you talking about why am i even
interested in this it's clearly a cult
we all knew it was a cult
we all thought you were [ __ ] when
you were talking about xenu
and an explosion of souls and that this
is how you
and auditing it was clearly a blackmail
operation you tell all your secrets to a
guy that records them
and then you can't get out it's
blackmail we know what it is
it's epstein's island we get it everyone
else gets
it why is there 35 documentaries about
this
this is like explaining santa claus not
being real yeah we know that
nobody's shocked about that everyone's
like oh this is this uh have you seen
have you read going claire have you seen
going clear
it's amazing it's all the that get
wrapped up into this culture it's a cult
like anything else like anything else
it's not that interesting it's only
interesting
because celebrities are in it let's be
very clear
no one would give a [ __ ] about
scientology if it was
poor people only and a lot of them are
broke
but if tom cruise wasn't in it would no
one would give a [ __ ]
they'd be like oh yeah those people
believe that uh you know they're all
alien life forms that were uh yeah yeah
they're into that
but because like tom cruise is in it
everybody's like wow this is
uh it's pretty cool
but it's secure they're gonna have q and
on docs is my point
in a few years there's going to be
somebody talking about that they were in
queueing on they were like well i was a
follower of q
for years and then i finally realized
when my husband kidnapped my son
because i thought he thought i was
selling them the clintons
and he kidnapped my son and he drove him
across state lines
i realized the error of my ways i
realized that i shouldn't have been just
reading those q
drops every day i should have been
looking for work
it's going to be queuing on docs all
these people whose brains have been
[ __ ] toasted in this country
at dairy queen what do you think that
guy was reading 10 minutes before he's
shouting onion rings
in the drive-thru people are just
shouting onion rings at the sky
onion rings give me onion rings
like a child
i just wanted to see like just a fat
hispanic woman walk out
with just a bucket of onion rings and
start shoving them in his mouth
just shoving them in his mouth
let's talk about meat dude they sent me
this meat and i loved it they sent me
some really really good meat and i
really appreciate it they have the best
cuts of american beef
wagyu and lamb waigu wagyu wagyu
wagyu that's how you say it
i know exactly what i'm getting and
where it's from and now you can really
taste the difference
united harvest works directly with north
american family farms that uphold the
highest standards
of quality and animal care and listen
i'm one of these guys that like they
sent me a lot of stuff they sent me pork
chops they sent me everything it was
really good rib by steaks new york
strips
top sirloin really good i really enjoyed
this lamb loin chops perfect for holiday
party
they're tender packed with flavor you
get them they come right to the house
you kind of leave them out on the
counter let them naturally defrost and
you spice them up throw them on a grill
throw them in the oven they're quick
easy to cook i really enjoyed this this
is one of the products that i really
enjoyed
because it's food the flavor is out of
this world premium quality is built in
every step of united harvest sustainable
farming process
which includes no hormones gmos or
unnecessary antibiotics so basically
you're getting
you know really good high
quality meat that does not come from an
industrial factory farm
and it is not loaded with all of the
things that make meat
really typically and traditionally
unhealthy
so it's really good it tastes good you
know they're right here in the usa
you're supporting usa farmers
it's not imported from halfway around
the world meat delivery companies do
that all the time and that's the way
they
they cut costs but you're supporting
actual farmers in america and you're
getting really good cuts of perfect meat
and it's delivered overnight which is
amazing it comes right the next day
um i really enjoy it i mean they sent it
to me we made it you had it it was great
remember that you know we
we we cook meat here at the house all
the time here's what i want you to do go
to unitedharvest.com that's united
unitedharvest.com
and enter the promo code tim you get 20
off site wide with your order of 50
or more if you're doing a ketogenic diet
high protein diet paleo this is great
for all of that
so go to unitedharvest.com that's
unitedharvest.com and
enter the promo code tim 20 off site
wide with your order of 50
or more my favorite
memory as a child why do you say
no why are you saying no no
i'm on this my show i'm saying what my
favorite memory as a child
my favorite memory is a child
i mean you're really losing your mind
right now you're like you're like
overtired
my favorite memory of as a child
was eating sugar cereal okay okay
okay is that okay that's fine at my
friend's house
i don't know why you're laughing okay
now we would eat sugar cereal every
morning
we would eat things like lucky charms
count chocula and i've been trying to
replicate that feeling ever since
as an adult and i needed to find a
cereal with
zero sugar 11 grams of protein and only
three grams of
carbs right
in each serving with natural fruit
flavors
and and extracts that replace sugar
and i was able to do that
you know ask me what happened to my
friend that i used to
eat the magics uh not magics hold on
the sugary sugar the sugar cereal what
happened what happened to your friend
that you used to eat
grease his parents hit him with a car
magic spoon cereal is
a great cereal it's like you're eating
the sugar cereals as a child
but you're not you're eating a very
healthy alternative
if you're doing a ketogenic diet if
you're doing a paleo diet if you do well
not paleo really but
whatever high protein diet a sugar
elimination diet
it's very hard to find things to eat you
want to eat steak all day you don't you
need to
taste something a little sweet the
texture is cereal
so a magic spoon will help eliminate
one of the meals right you have three
meals a day magic spoon you'll take away
one of the milk you'd have a bowl of
magic spoon cereal
and you know and whatever a slice of
cheese or something and you're good
you know it's like a good snack
he's dead now
because they hit him with a car he had a
horrible life
no he didn't have a horrible life he
didn't really have a horrible life man
he had a good life but one day
it ended in the driveway of his house
[Laughter]
and his parents still let me come over
for cereal after we buried him they were
like hey
you can come over anytime you want
because you and john used to love cereal
and and i was like yeah thank you so
much and they're like we're still gonna
buy it
even though we don't need it they said
we're gonna buy it for john and you know
you pour out booze
at the grave of like an og original
gangster 440
pour 40 out of old english or some such
sometimes we would just pour lucky
charms out on the floor for john
even those parents did like they
intentionally hit him with the car that
was never proven but i saw it
i saw it from my porch
guys here's the thing if you don't buy
magic spoon they're going to get mad
you have to buy magic spoon because
otherwise
they're going to get really mad at the
ad but if all of you buy magic spoon
they can't get mad at what i say and
that's
truly the fun thing about comedy it is a
good cereal like everyone i give it to
likes it
whitney eats it all the time you know
and she's got her hair nine colors in
the past months so she's doing well
so i would just say to buy this cereal
so that i don't get in trouble
that's magicspoon.com tim dillon to
build your own custom variety box and
try today magicspoon.com
tim dillon there's great flavors okay
cocoa
fruity frosted and blueberry flavors
press brand new flavors
including peanut butter and cinnamon
these are really great
magicspoon.com tim dillon
we're just we're just we're just
sobering up right now
and everybody's invested in this idea
that nothing's ever going to change
it's so unhealthy it's so weird
that everybody's like figuring out a way
to hold on to trump
i'm like hey man get over it
on both sides the people that made trump
out to be hitler
think he's going to terrorize them
forever they're convinced
that he'll never go away they'll never
get a moment's peace
and they're still gonna get to watch
stephen colbert and
john oliver take down trump
what a takedown and they they think it's
never gonna end
i mean it's true and by the way the joke
i made last week
about kamala harris executing the ceo of
patreon
is a joke and it's not based on any
inside knowledge i have
about an actual event or planned events
that was made on our patreon episode
that wasn't a cue drop it was a joke
i don't believe at this point there's
any
military operation planned to take out
the ceo of patreon
though i don't necessarily
think it's completely out of the realm
of possibility
but that's just my belief system
about that it's gonna end and then
everybody's gonna be sitting there and
all the people
you know i talked to my little cousin
today
one of the good ones you know one of the
ones who uh i would let in my home
and he was seeing his dad he's like a
big conservative very funny guy
he's just so angry about the elect you
know he's like they stole it
they stole the other i don't know what
the hell happened with the election i
looked at
i looked at it and i've talked to some
some people that have looked at it
closer than i have there's
irregularities there's weirdness i don't
i haven't done a deep dive on the
election folks
i don't think the election is shadier
than any previous election
like the one in two 2000 where where
the supreme court decided that george w
bush would be the president
remember that i didn't i didn't you know
obama won twice um
it this is the way it goes this is like
what
happens it's always very close
there's always some type of irregularity
i don't know that it means that
there was an orwellian plot to steal the
election
from donald trump who if he had won
would be like yeah it was great
democracy in action if he had won he
just come out and go
the people's voice has been heard he
wouldn't give a [ __ ]
about anything and i don't know about
the vote counting from what i
understand the vote counting's done it's
not done in like a back alley by antifa
i mean is that who's counting the votes
i don't know
i'm gonna get so much hate on this
episode they're like you don't
understand
i'm like yeah well i don't know i also
don't care you care
you're an idiot that's that's before you
type that message to me realize i don't
give a [ __ ]
you give a [ __ ] go out go do the maga
march go to
jump around in the street in dc do
whatever you want
pound your fist make memes sing songs do
group tick-tock dances
he lost i i mean what do you want me to
do
it's it's it's oh your moment is over
the moment of glory
that was fake anyway has ended
the school play is over now and you must
go back to class
you had your moment you stood in front
of everyone and sang
now it's time to go back to class i
don't know what to tell you
i mean we're sitting with the knelt kid
and the nel kids and one of them was
like uh
fun kids smart great not as crazy as
you'd think
right you'd think they'd be crazy but
they were actually like smart business
people
all of their videos they're like jumping
off roofs
into a pool and then you sit down with
them at dinner and they're like well if
you look at the margins on a lot of that
it's like what
they're all business people and yes
they're fun they have fun
they party but they're like smart kids
right
yeah like these tick tock kids now have
you
the tick tock kids are now
becoming angel investors and they're
dumping like
money into companies like one of them
just
invested in some dog pet food company
that like chelsea handler
owns part of or something and they're
not like big time angel investors but
they're dumping in like 20 grand or
something and then they're tweeting
about you know they're going out and
they're being like hey i'm so happy
to be a part of wolf or whatever you
know whatever the [ __ ] company's name
is
you know they're i mean because
before the tick tock kids there was
something called
magcon and magcon
was called meet and greet convention and
there was a documentary about it on
netflix called chasing cameras about
this kid cameron dallas
i think he's been in rehab a bunch of
times like it didn't
he was like a big model and these were
kids that got really big on vine
vine was an app where they did six
second looping videos and there were
some comedians in new york
that were building followings on vine
not nearly as big
as these kids right because all the
social media apps are really just for
good-looking people
that's the secret everyone's like well
what's the secret be good-looking
that's the secret well what's the
strategy behind
be be good looking yeah but
if you post at a certain time yeah be
hot have
parents that are good-looking you be
good-looking
yeah but there's got to be another like
what's the algorithm don't
look like [ __ ] that's the algorithm
people want to look at you you've got a
shot
i do okay because i'm funny but
the good looking people just do better
because good-looking people people just
pretend they're funny
they're like we do comedy like all these
kids like we do comedies you really
don't do comedy
but you take your shirt off and you jump
around and girls
laugh because they don't want to admit
how much they want to [ __ ] you
see have you ever seen two good looking
people on a date like really good
looking people
they giggle at each other because they
just want to [ __ ] and they can't explain
that on a date
they can't say to each other like i just
want to [ __ ] you
so they're just kind of like laughing at
they're like oh yeah because they want
to [ __ ] each other
you know what i mean like that's the
whole energy of the whole thing so a lot
of these young
good-looking social media stars are just
goofy
and silly and people are like oh he's so
funny it's like no they're not that
funny you just want to [ __ ] them
you want to [ __ ] them that's all but
the vine stars that did this meet and
greet convention magcon
all bottomed down they ended up with
very little or nothing vine went out of
business
um they did not
parlay their success on that app into
anything else
and many of them just kind of like walk
around los angeles within a beanie
and they just look sad because it's all
over
right now all these social media manager
type people
in la know that and i'm sure they warn
the tick tock kids about the vaughn you
know it's like the ghost or
christmas future right you know it's
like look at that guy
he was once like you millions of
followers
people loved him high engagement you
know what he's doing now
nothing he's washed up and it's over
he's 21 years old he's 22.
he can finally legally drink and you
know what he's gonna do now
he's gonna drink himself to death
because he's got nothing
because he didn't build a business so
what all these kids are trying to do
and more power to them is build
businesses but there's 16 right right
they're like 19 some of them they're 20.
they don't know anything about business
so then what these social media guys do
is they're like they start getting
business people
like the winklevoss twins you know the
guys that got
facebook taken from them by mark
zuckerberg
so you got these guys with the tick tock
kids
doing like podcasts about business
and then they bring in other business
strategists you have like a business
trainer and then you have like a tick
tock kid
and listen i'm not hating on those kids
i get it i would do the same thing right
i'd be like yeah i want to make money
but like you just it's like a guy who's
like a business strategist
talking about he's like here's the thing
about capital markets
and then it's like bryce hall in a
hoodie just staring at him
like yeah man just nodding they're
getting like pretty big people
you know they're like uh today on the
podcast we have bryce hall and warren
buffett and they're going to discuss and
you're like what the [ __ ]
what is happening the the barstool guy
does a podcast with one of the kids
it's called bffs or whatever it's
probably not that bad
the barstool guy is a remarkably
successful guy i don't know
anything about i mean i know that i have
fans over there and i've gone on shows
there and i like everybody there but i
don't
i don't know anything about the genesis
of the company like my i know that it
you know the thing that drove me nice
about barcelona sports was saturdays and
for the boys
i just don't like i just don't like
slogans right yes or yes do i not like
slogans
yes or yes i just don't like that right
so and i knew my friends in long island
that were posting saturdays were for the
boys
were like unemployed loot i'm like no no
day is for the boys
every day should be for finding gainful
employment
you live with your mother saturdays are
for the boy like i just that
irked me but i liked that barstool was
like funny
raunchy non-pc [ __ ]
i think a lot of the people there are
talented but i don't know anything do
you know anything about the origins of
barstool sports no let me see if i have
any wi-fi i don't think i do
they are a major player in media right
wouldn't you say
oh big time i mean caller daddy all that
stuff it's huge
and dave portnoy is clearly kind of
would you say he's a visionary
yeah absolutely i think so he's very
smart
so he does a podcast with that kid josh
richards and um
i don't know what they discuss but
everyone's getting into podcasting now
all the tick tock like every
everybody's like hey let's just talk in
a microphone for an hour
okay so uh barstool sports was a
gambling newspaper in boston
in 2003. it's grown to become an online
phenomenon with a cult following of
individuals known as stoolies
so gambling newspaper
interesting it was a print publication
yeah
wow and did poor noise start that or it
was okay
that was dave what year 2003 in milton
massachusetts
wow and then it launched on the internet
and oh seven and
that's what everybody everybody wants to
be barstool sports
like everybody that's creating content
seems to want to be
like that type of enterprise yeah they
want their version of bar stool
and now seems to be the closest ones to
it because they've created this culture
around you know partying and you know
it's really popular with college kids
but like
that's the whole thing it's like
creating this culture barcelona sports
created a culture
and that that seems to be the most
successful right
you know i can't point to anything else
it's i mean even so on a much smaller
level you could look at like louis gomez
with the legion of skanks they created a
culture right yes
skank fest you have all those things um
but yeah it's interesting to see that
like
there's a lighting a cigarette i mean
it's just folks we're just it's a mess
today but what do you want us to do
we're not in the studio
we can barely breathe in the [ __ ]
house palm springs has been inundated
with
just literal drug addicts that are
wandering around
desert homeless are very strange
they all seem to have homes like they
seem to be kind of okay
right it's like the ultimate choosing to
be homeless situation out here yeah
i feel like i don't know why it's just
odd there's some real creatures
roaming the streets i came out here in
july man i didn't see a single
[ __ ]
well i came in when the riots started
when did they start may yeah around may
may june dude i came out here i thought
it was in a nuclear fallout shelter
there was nobody here
yeah i thought i was in one of those
towns when the hills have eyes that just
barely existed
they were just created to be bombed i
mean it was amazing
now everybody's coming back and all
these idiots are like oh it's great to
be out in the desert in january it's
like why
ryan phillippe was on barcelo sports
that's some nice things about the
podcast which we appreciate
thank you ryan phillippe what did he
call me a fish out of water in l.a
that's nice yeah that's because he's a
you know fish out of water like
like for me i'm like this good looking
successful guy so i'm like a fish in
water
but he's like a fish out of water he's
like you know it's like the elephant man
see the movie the elephant man where the
guy wears a paper bag over his head
and walks around the grove it's like tim
dillon in l.a
he's a fish out of war we'll see there's
a fish out of water when i'm dancing
with the demilio twins
you better respect me i'm kidding
i'm sad we had to cancel the
friendsgiving because i don't want gavin
newsom
to audit me gavin newsom by the way at
the french laundry
full dinner party great restaurant
thomas keller
one of the greatest chefs in america
they grow all of the produce they
i'm not even mad at newsome i'm mad at
him because i guess he's a hypocrite
but i never get mad at people from being
hypocrites because people just are
hypocrites
i mean it's just kind of funny that he
was having this dinner party
clearly indoors with like major health
department officials
see who was at that dinner party it was
like serious health people
that are sitting there with gavin newsom
drinking wine they're all having a
tasting menu
and by the way the world is literally
burning
i mean the state of california could not
be in worse shape
homelessness traffic housing crisis
covid economic collapse
problems with the police and gavin
newsom is eating a tasting menu
at the french laundry he's eating foie
gras yeah it was
dustin corcoran ceo of the california
medical association
and janice norman the group's lobbyist
and senior vice president jordan newsome
and several other guests november 6 at
the french laundry
for what what was this for um
it was a dinner party for the avenue
sims annual
[ __ ] the people fundraiser it was this
was the
annual [ __ ] the people fundraiser where
gavin newsom and noted uh
and yeah what was it for uh
lobbying on the behalf of california
doctors uh
attended a private 50th birthday dinner
for their friend jason kinney earlier
this month
the dinner was held in accordance with
state and county guidelines
huh the only thing that would have made
that funnier
was if they were attending crystalia's
birthday party
that would be the only thing that was
funnier if they were like uh gavin
newsom was attending
uh chris dalia's birthday at the french
laundry
that would be the only thing that made
it like a better headline
i love that he's just eating french food
elbow to elbow did they get coveted
before they went in
i'm assuming so not much details it's a
lot of it's private
but they said it was supposed to be
outdoors but that that's clearly indoors
it got cold it's cold it gets cold man
you got to close those doors
gavin newsom he's just this good looking
kind of he's a pimp
he's just a pimp of a dude he used to
[ __ ] that chick kimberly guilfoyle
yeah on fox news who now [ __ ] donald
trump jr
she's in it for love huh you say that
about kimberly
gilfoyle newsom she's in it for love
she's a woman that really likes a deep
emotional connection with the guy she's
with huh
that's what i think i'm just a casual
observer of her and yet that's what i
would feel
kimberly likes a man that's got a little
bit of cloud
kim likes some clout
when did he get elected in california i
didn't even pay attention to california
before i [ __ ] lived here and i barely
pay attention now
i don't know why their marriage fell
apart
probably because he kept quarantining
her
he kept he kept he kept giving her state
home orders
kept issuing her stay-at-home orders and
curfews
she said i've had enough i want to go
[ __ ] donald trump jr and talk about q
anon
they're like openly promoting q anon
right now yeah donald trump jr
is just it's the last thing they have
left they're just they're just openly
promoting cue
dude trump's gonna trump dude if the
last thing
it's the last thing he does if the
military has to walk him out of the oval
office
he just looks at everybody and he goes
i'm cute [ __ ]
that's the other thing about trump he
knows a good finale right it's all
reality tv
so he's got to do something big that's
why i tried to bomb iran
what's a big finale no he's gonna have a
media company
he's so stupid he's given nothing he's
gonna leave
he's running again in four years it's
never it's not going to be over
dude i remember the senior year i had
some of the best
some of the most fun i ever had in my
life
i remember senior summer
hanging out with even during senior
summer you started to see the people
from your
your school less and less by the
end of senior summer you all kind of
saying goodbyes and
it was time for everyone to go away to
college except tim dillon who went to
nassau community college because he's a
[ __ ] loser
uh but it doesn't matter because i
podcasted now with alex jones and
roseanne eat your heart out [ __ ]
um
i just love i go back to like give a
speech at my school i'm like
i've sat down with the greatest minds of
our generation
i have spoken to the greatest minds
to the minds of people that have shaped
our world how did i do that
how did i do that well i took drugs for
a decade
developed what some would call latent
schizophrenia
and then started started to
make connections with people that also
had that disease but were far more
successful than me
okay kids so take the student loans and
shove them up your ass
but that week when everyone was going to
school it's like you know
august whenever you knew
it was over you could feel it
even when people were like nah man we're
all
we're all gonna be and then yes
you know what's funny the first
thanksgiving
uh weekend everyone comes back
that first wednesday it feels a little
different
maybe you're all still friends you're
also hanging out probably
but by the next year by the next
wednesday
when everyone goes out and a lot of
people listen you're like what do you
mean friends bars going out thanksgiving
i have no idea what you're talking about
well we know but
wednesday before thanksgiving like when
it's the next year
it's like sophomore year in college like
it's been one year it's you see people
they're like strangers to you and they
were like your best friends
and like oh my god you we have we have
nothing in common
you're gone you're at another school you
have new friends you have new
experiences you have
you know you have new things going on
and i had i had nothing going i was so
embarrassed
because i would go out and i was always
funny and people liked me but i i was at
a community college
i was like so embarrassed that my
friends were coming back from
universities
i'm still embarrassed i didn't go to
college and i've done better than all of
them
have i not mentioned who i've sat in
rooms with
i mean i'm i'm a national media figure
myself candace owens alex jones
roseanne we are your media
you get it we're the media now oh you
don't like it
tech writer with purple hair [ __ ] off
no one cares what you like you
blue-haired freak
write any article you want i'm the media
[ __ ]
i am and dave portnoy
barstool sports and me
we're the media sorry we took it over
okay you could tell the souls burger
family the new york times to go [ __ ]
themselves
in their [ __ ] loafers in their boat
shoes
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm the [ __ ]
media but even though
i have a privileged position
as a member of our as a proud member of
our new media i am still
kind of embarrassed i didn't go to
college and i think i should be forever
i should be a little embarrassed not a
lot about i know i did cool [ __ ]
i sold subprime mortgages i bought a
house i i was in rehab
i get it i did a cool thing too
but even like little dan carney when
he's telling me about florida state and
the whole thing
i feel not you so much because you went
to that christian cult school
but when dan's talking about florida
state which is just a party school it's
not really a good school
but i feel like oh this is a college
experience i can't relate to that i
really can't right
so i feel a little almost insecure about
it that i didn't go to
college right not that actually i am
much smarter
than most people who went to college i
didn't even choose to be
you know what i mean but i still feel a
little insecure about it which i think
is a healthy thing
i think it's a healthy thing to feel a
little insecure because it keeps me
grounded
as a as an all-powerful member of the
new media
i need to be a little grounded because i
don't want to lose touch with the people
you understand so i don't like to lose
touch with the people
that's why like roseanne smokes for
example she doesn't want to lose touch
with the people
but i was very embarrassed when i went
to
thanksgiving eve and i was like at a
community college and i had
nothing going on and everybody else was
at
better schools and they were like colle
they were like looked
like college kids and they came back and
i was just kind of like hey yeah i'm the
same
you know nothing's going on in my life
but they're like what are you up to i'm
like i don't know
how did i win a did i win a debate
championship at national community
college
was it the first gold medal that that
school has ever won
yes 100 and did i defeat
two women yes i did yes i did
in the sport of talking i defeated two
ladies one white one asian stomped them
out
at the national tournament in
philadelphia stomped on their
faces okay
in my ill-fitting cheap suit
but i knew it
you know and then and then obviously you
know
like you know you grow up you lose touch
you lose touch with people they're gone
they're just gone they go away
it doesn't matter what you want
i will say the debate part of college
for me
was the only thing that even resembled a
college experience
because when you were on the debate team
at nassau community college you got to
travel
to other colleges that like existed that
were real
and you would debate kids and then you
would get to go to a national tournament
at the end of the year the first one was
in los angeles
california have you heard of this city
have you heard of this place
it was in woodland hills
i stayed at the woodland hills marriott
my debate partner kenny who sold me a
house
that destroyed my life but i don't
really have any will towards him i still
kind of like him
because he was fun that's how much i
that's how much of a you know a uh
what what word am i looking for
when you say i put a uh uh i put a uh
premium that's how much of a premium i
put on someone being fun
you can sell me a house and destroy
a decade of my life as long as we
as long as you're fun in a car
we're good truly we're good so i like
him
but woodland hills
marriott debate national tournament
had sex with a woman for the first time
biological woman not
w-o-m-x-n an actual woman with an a
white not latinx sadly
would have been hot if i got a lot of
tanks
latinx or is it la tinx or latinx
la tinx la tinx sounds like somebody's
name
yo you gotta call la tinx
la ting sounds like somebody's got good
coke real good fish scale
yo cola tink she got the [ __ ] right now
and uh i felt like i started you know i
was like oh this is cool
and then the next year i went to
philadelphia and uh
that was the year i just wanted to win i
wanted to win i was all about winning i
was like i'm good at debate i want to
win this [ __ ]
and i smoked pot all weekend and i drove
around listening to like beanie siegel
that song in the air you can feel it in
the air driving around my shitty car
and i won i won the gold medal and it
was the first
in our shitty community college that
looks like a prison
that's literally two blocks away from a
prison in long island
first gold medal in their history that's
my college experience there it is
right right there nothing really nothing
to write home about
i met a lot of great people at nassau
community college i met a woman who told
me something that haunts me to this day
chubby woman wore those like those like
terry cloth pants
and flip-flops in october she was spoken
a parliament light and she goes listen
people people think i can't drink and
raise my daughter i can do both
haunts beetle this day sometimes when i
lay my head on the pillow
i just think of that woman and what she
said
she said it's so nonchalantly to me
outside of our biology class we were
both failing
she goes people say hey you can't drink
and raise your daughter uh i can do both
just took a puff on a parliament line i
said this is this is a
a woman who knows who she is that's what
i like
you ever meet somebody who just knows
who they are like this woman knows who
she is
so comforting in a sea of pretenders
everybody's trying on a different face
to please the masses
not this lady she knew who she was
she knew her limitations and apparently
she didn't have many
i can do both
there was not a skin till of arnie she
was not kidding
she was deadly serious
i used to go to something called the
international buffet in between classes
which was an asian fusion buffet which
means that there was sushi but also
french fries
asian fusion sushi but also
have an ice cream cone miso soup but how
about a chicken nugget
asian fusion international buffet
garden city long island fusion different
types of food
spicy tuna roll slice of pizza asian
fusion
and i would feel so sick afterwards in
class
just because of the soy and the msg and
the sugar
i would feel so sick i remember once i
went in and vomited
in the bathroom and i vomited on my on
my shirt
and i just walked back in without a care
and someone looked at me and went did
you just vomit and i went yeah and they
just laughed they went
that's how shot i was
and i wish i wish till this day i'm like
i had gone to a college i would have
came out of the closet earlier
i would have been happier i would not be
funny i would not have bought that house
i would not have destroyed my life and
then who the [ __ ] would want to listen
to those stories
oh i went to a college in new england
and you know i met
carl or whatever and we've been happy
ever since
breeding [ __ ] you know australian
shepherds
and by the way [ __ ] monster shakes in
palm springs these two gay ogres
i hate these two people these are these
the two most
ogre these two gay ogres who found each
other
and open up this shitty frozen yogurt
shop
that serves this thing called dole whip
dole whip
is sorbet that comes out of the frozen
yogurt machine
it is disgusting nobody wants it
and it's for like toothless elderly
people
i don't even know who it's for it's for
latinx people
and me and ben went in there today
because we had to get candles in the cvs
i thought maybe we'll just get a little
frozen yogurt and then the frozen yogurt
was literally not frozen it was it
described the texture of it
cream that's expired in the fridge that
you pour out of a little carton this is
like the third time i've walked in there
and i've said to the guy
you can't run the place like this
like i don't know what you and your
boyfriend are doing here you and your
husband
you're just getting [ __ ] hopped up on
poppers and [ __ ] each other in the
back
i don't know what you're doing but this
is like a business don't you have a
business license
you are both monsters at least there you
can't sue them for false advertising
monster shanks two [ __ ] monster i've
seen him and his husband in there
together
it's a real [ __ ] interesting
but [ __ ] them but that's the thing
i just i just feel a lot like i don't
know why this feels like a very
it feels like high school to college it
feels like it's weird
not that kamal and biden or college
don't [ __ ] please don't give me any of
that [ __ ] i'm not saying that
i'm saying this feels like a very weird
transition between like people that are
still pretending that nothing's gonna
change and people that are understanding
it a lot so much
is gonna change in the next 12 to 16
months i think people's heads are gonna
[ __ ] spin
i think people's heads are gonna [ __ ]
spin with the amount of change
coming get [ __ ] ready those tick tock
kids are getting ready they're trying to
[ __ ]
start businesses good for them they're
taking their hoodies off and they're
trying to [ __ ]
be angel investors i mean it's an absurd
society
but this is what where we're at big
holiday site wide sale at finchero
watches these are the beautiful watches
that sponsor the show ben wears them
they look really really great i wear
them occasionally i'm not huge in the
watches but
these i like you know and i love them as
gifts for other people okay
i really think that these are great
gifts and the holidays are coming up
the great thing about ventura watches is
they're offering a really good deal for
a lot of my listeners
all of my listeners you go to tim to
venturawatches.com
sale site-wide discount off your entire
order and they cover all shipping costs
okay promo code is auto applied at
checkout
if you go to venturawatches.com tim it's
really really amazing
so v-i-n-c-e-r-o watches dot com
backslash tim that is v-i-n-c-e-r-o
watches dot com backslash tim these are
beautiful
watches they do not break the bank
they're not overly expensive
it is truly truly amazing and
i i i just think this is a great way to
get a gift for somebody
whether they're a close relative or
close friend or somebody that you
you don't know maybe you work with it's
a professional relationship
it's just great it's not super expensive
and we know money is tight right now
it's been a crazy year
it's been a crazy [ __ ] year but
everybody deserves a holiday
some type of holiday you know everyone
deserves a holiday except
a lot of the people in iglesia de cristo
in the philippines don't believe in
holidays but
and we respect that as well so but many
people
you know they i think they give gifts
dylan iglesia my doctor dr ramos gelato
ramos was in iglesia
my friend michael's uh wife vanessa's
brother knows him
because they all they all know each
other oh interesting
vincerowatches.com backslash tim
it is amazing get the watch take a photo
of it i'll repost you on my instagram
thank you
did you hear on the news that nobody
that had a ridge wallet got covered
oh really that's what i heard they said
nobody that had a ridge rod a lot of
people don't even know what a ridge
wallet is it's a minimal
front pocket wallet that's designed to
streamline what you carry every day
did you know it has thirty thousand five
star reviews
on what is that i guess their website
oh nice what do you mean on their
website
what i thought it was amazon is it not
on amazon i don't think it's on amazon i
think it's only on ridge
it's on ridge.com they have reviews well
yeah well you don't want people going to
amazon to buy the wallet even if it's
there because we want them to use the
promo
so don't even i mean amazon you're
giving bezos money they're trying to
[ __ ] take your life
but nobody my point is that nobody with
a ridge wallet has ever gotten governed
so i don't know if that's causation or
causality
i don't know a ridge wallet is a small
it's a coyote ben relax
they're like small dogs yeah i know i
saw five of them on your block once i
don't give a [ __ ] about nothing
i thought i was a bear they like flipped
out
they were like well this night's gonna
end in a way we didn't think
just a pack of coyotes walking around
about to get their asses handed to them
they took a look at me they're like we
thought we were like badasses they're
out like prowling cats trying to kill
cats
then they see me they're like we're
about to get shredded right now
we're about to get our throats stomped
on by this bear
who's just wandering around eagle rock
at two o'clock in the morning
well my point about the ridge wallet is
it's a metal wallet you can put a couple
of cards in it's not like uh
a uh uh you know traditional leather
wallet or with these big wallets that
get really fat and
you know unmanageable this is a very
sleek
it's really sleek like the word sleek
was invented for the ridge wallet
you know and negative meaning negative
of covert because nobody
that has a ridge wallet has ever had the
coronavirus
why is that are we not allowed to make
that claim even though it's factually
true
i don't think ridge would care other
products would care but ridge would not
they're cool with it well they
understand that i'm reporting the news
and that's a fact youtube may not be
cool with it we'll see
well i'm just saying
it's observation that i've made like
people say if you take vitamin d
you're you can safeguard against
coronavirus it's true
what do you know what do you mean it's
true you don't know if it's true but
that's what people say
what dr rhonda patrick said she's not a
medical doctor
the point is this she's not is she not
she's not a medical doctor
she's got a doctorate a lot of people
have doctorates you know
she could have a doctor in latin for all
i know
what i'm saying is this if you have a
ridge wallet you're not going to get
covered
now if you want to get covered i guess
have a regular wallet
the ridge really is helping me out a lot
because i'm a very disorganized
guy and i'm a mess but the ridges helped
me
really get myself organized and stay
safe from the coronavirus covet 19.
which is ravaging all across the land
but
not me because i got a ridge i had a
friend once
uh who lost his ridge and the next day
tested positive for coronavirus
for covered 19.
i don't know why i think it was because
the ridge wallet has vitamin d
in the metal that seeps into your pores
says pretend dr ronda patrick
i'm kidding folks we're kidding we're
jesters
but buy this wallet please it helps our
show it helps us
it'll help you because it's a good ass
wallet
go to ridge.com tim tim ridge dot com
slash cham use code tim link in
description
ridge dot com slash tm and use code tim
link in description
but the change that's coming i think is
going to be quite drastic
and people are going to be shocked and
people are going to be like wait a
minute what happened
that's going to be like yeah well we
were in this really contentious
time for four years where everybody was
on a side
and everybody was fighting and that's
where people derived all the meaning
from life
in the battle all the meaning that
people got
out of life these last four years has
been fighting
someone or something whether they were
really fighting them or not
that's the entirety of the last four
years
and what i think is going to happen now
is that
with trump going away sorry guys
i think that that's going to we're still
going to have the fighting to a degree
but it's going to be lessened
dramatically lessened
by circumstances and then
the list eight months kova's been going
on for eight months
covet has reshaped and restructured the
economy in horrible ways
we have whitney webb on to talk about
the people that are trying to use kovid
to to
reshape things permanently and whether
they're going to be successful or not
so i'm not discounting that i'm not
saying that that is a
completely conclusion to come to right
that this is going to have lasting
effects it will like 911.
it's gonna have lasting effect we're
still fighting a fake war on terrorism
kind of
sure even though we're not we are
and kovid will still be around but it's
going to go away
and then when it's done people are going
to go back out
they're going to go back out people are
going to have to go back out and figure
out how they're going to earn a living
how they're going to how they're going
to make money
relationships going to end coveted
relationships going to end
friendships are going to end dude i look
at some of my friends now and i'm like
do i like this person or have we been
quarantined
are we even friends or are we
just reacting to this weird
situation that we're in there are people
in relationships right now
that they know the vaccine means it's
over
they know a vaccine means it over it's
i have friends that i know
when a vaccine or whenever herd immunity
when the cases start
plummeting and people can go back out on
the road again
i have friends i know i'll barely speak
to
and that's okay because i know that this
was a time that meant something that
mattered
it's we all lived through it together we
all got through it
however we got through it but i know
that like
i don't don't make too many decisions
right now
right because when things end
you're gonna want the freedom to then
evaluate things and go
wait a minute this is not the life i
want this is not
these are not the people i want to
surround myself with
you know me and carney were on the road
and it was so wild to be on the road
doing stand-up comedy for the first time
in
probably five months when i started
stand up
it was september august september of
and i had gone about a decade and i
you know almost 11 years without taking
more than i would say a week off
maybe 10 days maybe and that was once or
twice
i had done stand-up comedy for the
majority of that time for about a decade
i mean
all all the energy that i had in my life
was devoted to doing stand-up comedy
wherever i could and then the quarantine
happened
and also podcasting and sketches or
whatever but and then the quarantine
happened and for the first time
i didn't have something to do on tuesday
night
i didn't have to go to the comedy store
and do a spot and
i had 37 or 40
weekends booked for this year before
i had to cancel my tour because of
corona because they canceled
everything so i was
sitting in an apartment with no stand-up
and no weekends and then this podcast
became my main focus and this podcast
will remain
my main focus even when things open up
because we do a show here that's good
and it's interesting and it's funny
hopefully and
and people enjoy listening to it it'll
always be
my main focus but i also love stand-up
but i love getting out of my house i
love doing stand-up
i love the time you know the shows we
had in west palm and
tampa and dallas and all these places
were great
and nashville and and getting out and
seeing real people
you miss that you miss seeing human
beings not
not after a few weeks doing it you want
to come right back home
you hope somebody eats another bat you
go lock me down again
newsome lock me down
but you you know i'm kidding you need to
be out there you need to meet people
but you know dana lived in new york he
was a kid pursuing what he wanted to do
doing stand-up going out having fun
dating people
all the new york [ __ ] like i'm a new
york guy you know and then quarantine
happened and he moved back home it was
like this culture shock and like
you know what i mean so me and him then
emerged
and it was like tough because we didn't
we're spending all this time together
and like you barely know how to be
around another human being
because i've only been around you and
you're like a vault of emotion you know
you don't really show emotions
so like when i was with that kid like me
and him like and and it was great we had
a great time and we we worked
out our [ __ ] because it was like you're
in close
proximity with another human being and
you you had been in jail
you had just gotten out of jail and now
you're like oh [ __ ]
life is starting again and then it ended
up being great and i think dan's going
to come out here and move out here and
and be more a part of what we do and i'm
happy about that
but this is what i mean i'm using that
as just a little example of like
you know you're gonna get out of jail
folks
you're gonna get out of jail so don't
be too certain
about everything until you're out of
jail and then when you're out of jail
you might
you might say to yourself hey listen
i want to go back to jail which is what
a lot of people do recidivism rates very
high a lot of people like to go back to
prison
they get out they go you know the
outside's not for me i don't want to
work at
walmart maybe i'll move some maybe i'll
move some weight on the street
let me get into the numbers game a
little bit i learned my lesson i know
how to be a good criminal now i'll be
good at it
but it's going to be interesting to see
how
the world and and and people
that i know you know deal with this
because this has been this has [ __ ]
our heads up
this is [ __ ] everybody i know his head
up everybody i know
their head has been [ __ ] up if your
head has not been [ __ ] up i mean
you're a cold-blooded sociopath and god
bless you i respect that and i admire it
but for most people this thing has
[ __ ] our heads up
not being able to go out see our
friends and our families i mean how many
nice things do i say about my family
every week i am so disheartened
to not be seeing them for christmas and
thanksgiving this year
and also retroactively for the past five
years
but there's going to be a new chapter
coming and i think people are scared
of that and i think people are scared of
that because i think so many people
some some people are doing well now i'm
doing good we're doing good the show's
doing good
i hope it keeps doing good i think a lot
of people are not doing good and they're
used to maybe they're used to that
and they're used to being bitter or
cynical or angry or depressed or
whatever
i think people get comfortable wherever
they are and they look at what's going
on around them and they go well this
will always be
there'll always be this external stimuli
there'll always be this
you know noose around my neck but
it's not it's going to be loosened
you're going to be able to go out
you know and i don't mean go out just
physically i mean like
mentally in your head you're going to be
able to live in a world
hopefully without this [ __ ] happening
all the time and i i i think the media
is going to chill out
i think everyone's gonna show the [ __ ]
out maybe i'm wrong
i can hear people getting so mad at this
episode they're like no it's
no it won't no it's not
you don't know dude it's gonna be like
trust the plan
you don't know it's gonna be like this
forever and ever
because you like it that's the thing you
like it that's why you don't want to
envision another way
you've gotten so used to this you like
sitting on your couch and hating donald
trump
it gives you something to do or
loving donald trump it gives you
something to do
it gives your life a sense of purpose to
sit there
and be on a team and root for a team and
root against another team
this is what gives you a sense of uh
identity
and unfortunately i think that's gonna
go away and you're gonna have to do
something else like i don't know
scrabble scrapbooking
so many great scrapbooks got [ __ ] up
by trump like so many middle-aged women
who would have just been really good
scrapbookers
it got [ __ ] up by trump they just had
to sit there and drink wine and curse
the tv for four years
there would have been some really cool
family photo albums being made
instead i have ants on on facebook
talking about q and
on instead of doing what they should be
doing like kicking ass in the kitchen
and scrapbooking ladies
so how's about we get back to that
let's get off reddit let's stop with the
pretend you're hunting pedophiles and
everybody's going to guantanamo bay and
then jesus is going to come down and
cancel your student loan debt and
you know going to take you to sonic one
last time
before you ascend let's cut all that
[ __ ] out
it's not it's not gonna happen move the
[ __ ] on
life is not supposed to be the same
goddamn
thing forever and the last four years
have
felt like forever the last eight months
have felt like forever
we're in a lockdown again nancy pelosi
is somehow
at 99 years old again
the speaker of the house again
they never leave hillary clinton's in
the news again this week like
none of them ever stop none of them ever
go away it's boring i want to leave the
country rogan went to austin i want to
get out of the country
truly i want to get out of the [ __ ]
country we did a deep covered clean on
the house
i'm moving out of palm springs we're
getting out of here i'm out of the
desert
i'm moving because i believe in moving
all the time
i'm moving into the valley in la i'm
gonna stay there for a while we'll see
what the [ __ ] happens
maybe in a year i go to texas maybe i go
[ __ ] it i want to go to florida go to
texas go wherever i don't care
you gotta keep moving it keeps you alive
you know like that's what
that's what you need in life and i feel
like the aversion to it you know that
dinner i had the other night where
everybody's like oh trump's not going
anywhere and
nothing's going to change i'm like dude
it's all going to change
everybody going to college no one's
gonna be friends anymore
or you will but it'll be different
trump will be around but it'll be
different he'll say something and
everybody go yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he'll do the
media he'll do the round of interviews
i mean don't worry about it you're not
gonna you're not gonna have to go cold
turkey on trump
i don't think he's disappearing tomorrow
you're not gonna have to do cold turkey
you'll take your suboxone there'll be a
phase out
it'll be a gradual step down process but
i guarantee you a year from now
you know somehow trump's still in office
a year from now
still covered going on people are
sending me chunks of this episode like
hey smart ass remember what you said
i'm like well i was wrong but i i do
believe
that people are just gonna have to
accept that
a phase is coming to an end here and
then a new phase is going to begin it
could be worse could be better i don't
know what the [ __ ] going to happen
but that's why i'm i'm physically
changing locations
you know i think we're going to start
doing different types of content we're
always going to do this podcast
we're building a new studio talk about
the new studio oh should we reveal it
what it's going to look like now well
we're building it no no i mean
why would you even suggest that it's the
worst idea ever
when i said talk about it i mean talk
about very general terms what do you
mean should we reveal what it's going to
look like now
kind of what kind of i'm getting a guy
it's going to look like rogan's in texas
we're having we're having the exact same
studio
that rogan built in texas we're going to
we're going to do that
dude what if we did that that's so funny
what if we did that as a bit
oh that's so funny why don't we do that
we should
but tell them tell them tell them in
very vague and general terms
um what is the studio now it's a black
curtain it's a black curtain in my
bedroom
yeah we're gonna keep it's gonna be like
the void it's gonna be like you know the
the black box but it's gonna be there's
gonna be pop to it it's going to be
it's going to be fun you're going to dig
it it's going to feel like a vortex
going to feel like
it's going to be in jeffrey epstein's
temple
we just signed a lease we didn't want to
go into it we didn't want to ruin it
we didn't want to ruin it but we got us
a new studio new things
new content we got a new show we might
debut
kind of that we've done no work on but
we discussed briefly at dinner
new things are happening
and i i think that there's a lot of fear
i hired a personal trainer that i'm
getting into queuing on
i'm trying to survive i got to not smoke
anymore i don't really smoke but
i smoke you know if you met those people
you don't really smoke but they smoke
cigarettes
but they don't but they do i'm trying to
survive a little bit
so i'm trying to don't send me messages
about that you are a better personal
trainer and that i should use you
please stop with that i appreciate them
people like i'll do it for free i'm like
i know you will but that doesn't give me
confidence in your abilities
you all do it for free i know you will
some of the people that send me those
messages i'm like look at you
i'm going to take advice from you
um but there's there's a lot of new [ __ ]
coming
and i i want to embrace that i don't
want to be a person that's afraid of
that
a lot of comedians that i'm friends with
that are very funny
have not embraced social media or
podcasting or
any digital content and those people are
unfortunately
behind they've fallen way behind
to a point where they're probably not
going to catch up ever ever
they're not going to not probably
there's no probably about it there's not
going to catch up
and it's not maybe for lack of talent
although in some cases it is i think
it's for a lack of
vision and a lack of like they don't
want to fail they think they're too good
to fail you know one of the greatest
things anyone ever told me is this guy
mike lawrence who's a comedian
who's from new york who lives in la now
when somebody said somebody goes yeah i
don't want to ask to do that
comedy show because maybe i'm not good
enough to do it
and or they said i'm not ready to do it
they didn't say i'm not good enough they
said i'm not ready to do it
and mike lawrence looks at them and goes
are you too good to fail
are you too good to fail because that's
what we do that's what i did for years
with
different podcasts until you know me and
ben found each other and made this work
so i think that's what it is there's a
lot of people that are too good to fail
and they don't want to fail they don't
want to go on youtube and have no
subscribers in the beginning
and for a very long time or they don't
want to start making videos that aren't
funny until they find a way to make them
funny
or they don't want to they don't want to
make mistakes publicly because that's
what you have to do with social media
when you go digital you got to make all
your mistakes publicly
comedy shows you make them in front of a
few people at a time handfuls of people
and then tens of people and then maybe
hundreds of people
but online you're making you're making
mistakes in front of everyone
celebrities people in the industry
people that are better than you that
have more followings so
a lot of people just don't want to fail
and they think they're too good to fail
but that's a bad attitude to have that's
a
horrible attitude to have you know
you know who didn't have that attitude
yeah you know
who never thought he was too good to
fail donald trump
donald j trump
he tried everything he did and a lot of
the things that he tried
failed and he failed repeatedly
remarkably so in major ways
and he just kept going and kept trying
different things
and then eventually you know he he was
able to
start a very you know profitable and
successful cult
and that's what we should all be trying
to do is my point
and unfortunately that has come to an
end yeah but don't worry
because he's running in four years he's
gonna win
and that's when hillary and barack go to
guantanamo
it's just four years away
four easy payments of 365 days
and you will get because when he's
inaugurated in four years
that's when they go to guantanamo and
the rapture happens
and christ comes down that's when it all
works out so just sit tight
don't worry about it it's all gonna
happen
that's right and you hug your friends
before they go away to college
and you look at them and go we're always
gonna be best buddies right
we're always gonna be friends you look
at the girl you're [ __ ] the guy
you're [ __ ] whatever and you go
hey just because we're at different
schools it doesn't matter
we're always gonna love each other we're
always gonna be
it's this is gonna work it's gonna work
nothing's gonna change
you look at each other and you go
nothing's going
to change i had a friend literally say
those words to me
they said nothing's going to change and
you know what happened
they overdosed on heroin thank you for
listening